hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer questions
from one of my foreign readers swan 55
who was asking about Twitter and how to
use it to market your business in your
products so a quick story about me on
Twitter when I first saw the service I
thought it was pointless and I wouldn't
use it I saw you know people talking
about their cats and where they're
getting lunch and I didn't really care
about that but then I did a quick search
for my name and found the people we're
talking about me on Twitter and they
were sharing content for my articles and
talking about what I was up to on
Twitter and I wasn't part of the
conversation so that's what got me to
join and at first I was just listening
to see what people were saying and
recognizing champions and thinking
people and then I started to get more
involved instead of posting and started
to becoming an expert in thought leader
and I found a lot of value from using
Twitter for my business so I'm going to
share with you five ways that you can
use Twitter to market your products and
hopefully can use some of them to two
great business so the first one is you
use twitter to sell and i haven't had
experience really with this and i don't
really believe in using this method but
i wanted to put it up there because
that's what most people think at the
start and this method is basically
you're you're pushing links out and
you're just promoting your product out
there you know however many times a day
you want to you want to put out there
sometimes of doing hundreds of posts
every day with affiliate links or links
to your own products and you know you're
hoping somebody's doing a search and
you're coming up right away because you
posted it so recently and they go on the
land on your page and sign of your
newsletter or your buy your product I
don't have a lot of experience with that
I don't know how much it works I know
when I see those I never click on the
links and I don't go and buy those
products but if people are doing it
there's got to be some money some money
in it so that's something you can
explore but I don't recommend it I
prefer using as Twitter as a way to
build relationships people and from
there you can generate some business so
the next one is become an expert
and here what you're doing is you're
trying to establish yourself as a
thought leader for whatever industry
you're in so for me I talk about
entrepreneurship and I'm seen as an
expert in entrepreneurship and people
follow me on Twitter to hear what I have
to say about entrepreneurship and
articles i'm reading and famous quotes
that inspire me and new content we're
coming up with and that's a reason to
follow me on twitter and then from there
people want to do business with me
because people want to do business with
the leaders in the experts in the
industry so you can use twitter to
establish yourself as an expert in
whatever industry you're in so you
didn't mention what you were selling
their what products you were trying to
market but whatever it is I tried to set
up a schedule of tweets to go out to
showcase how you're the most
knowledgeable person in the world about
whatever product it is that you're
selling and how useful it can be for
people and then from there people become
interested they look at your profile
they look at your website and they want
to come up and buy your products or
services so it's a little bit of a
longer strategy to establish out
expertise but you're attracting higher
quality clients who will likely buy more
from you stay longer firmer friends get
tuned to the media on and on and on and
on so definitely worth it in my opinion
the third way you can use it is the
prospect and what you're doing here is
you basically look for keywords that
people are typing in who are potential
customers for you and you can do it by
location as well so if you have a
physical location you can geosearch so
you can say within you know 20
kilometers or 20 miles of whatever
location or just in whatever city or
whatever country and you're looking for
people who are tweeting about certain
keywords and then you can respond to
them so an example if you had a coffee
shop you could you know search for the
word coffee and see what people are
tweeting and if somebody is you know
within 10 miles or 10 kilometers of your
location and they're saying I really
need a coffee then it's an opportunity
for you to connect with them and
introduce yourself and so start building
relationship with them for a while I was
even tracking the keywords entrepreneur
and help or business and help and people
were asking questions online on Twitter
and I would just start responding to
people and start building relationships
with people
there was necessarily business model
it's just something that I impassioned
about and really enjoy doing and I now
haven't done it because I get so many
questions coming at me that making these
videos takes up a lot of time and I
don't really have the time to do that
anymore but it was a great way to start
making some important connections at the
beginning and if I had something to sell
on my site if I answered their question
really helped them out they're going to
go to my Twitter bio look at my link and
click on my website and if I had a
product some of them would buy it so
it's a great way to start introducing
yourself to people who are potential
customers for you number four is connect
and what you can do here is you try to
introduce yourself to people who could
have a meaningful impact on your
business so connectors media potential
partners influencers people who could
refer business to you or say good things
about you that would lead to business
coming into your company and you can use
twitter is a great way to be able to
connect with them so you can introduce
yourself to them you can tweet out some
of the messages that they're writing you
can comment on some of their tweets so
basically if people are doing on an
ongoing basis and I notice it online to
people who often respond to my tweets
are retweeting what I'm writing I
noticed some and if it happens enough
then i'll usually click on their site
and i've become curious and what they're
doing so if you do it enough times if
you've kind of identified the people who
you want to go after and introduce
yourself to that could be a great way to
get on their radar screen and prompt
some kind of dialogue and introduction
to be able to then hopefully do some
business together longer term i also use
twitter when I'm first connecting with
people who are meeting locally so if
somebody is in Toronto and I've
scheduled a meeting with them I'll
quickly see if they have a Twitter
account or not to then be able to
connect with them and learn a little bit
about them before I end up going and
meeting with them so quick example is
meeting with a potential client downtown
here in Toronto and I researched the
person's Twitter account and found out
that she really liked a certain bakery
that was close to her office so I my way
down I stopped off at the breaker II
picked up some treats and brought them
to the meeting and so it's her favorite
bakery you know
lots of treats so the meeting started
off on a great foot and went well from
there on as well so it's a great way to
kind of learn a little bit about the
people the research into them before you
meet them and allows you to kind of gear
your conversation towards things that
maybe you have in common that you can
kind of get in there faster and make
that connection a little bit more easy
so that's number four and then the last
one that I would use it to do is update
your customers so here people will post
news updates or different updates about
what's going on at the business and it's
a great way for customers to kind of
keep track of what you're up to what
you're doing now this only works if you
have customers who actually care about
your business right if you're doing the
first one and all you're doing is
selling you're not gonna have people who
are actually following you and care
about your updates so you have to make
sure that you have a loyal fan base and
from there you can use the updates to
kind of keep in touch with them one
thing that will do with on the update
side at least is we'll post information
about what's going on in our website but
then we'll also try to follow some of
our customers and look for ways to
recognize them so what we try to do is
send a brownie every week to somebody on
our list and we look for ways on Twitter
people to do that so an example one of
our authors or customers was on Twitter
and posted that she couldn't go to work
and she had to work from starbucks
because the air conditioning on a very
hot summer day was broken at her office
she was working from starbucks so we saw
that we you know responded by Twitter
and then we sent her a brownie in the
mail to say you know I hope the air
conditioning gets fixed soon and here's
some sweet treats to keep it going while
you're working out of starbucks and she
was really grateful and the fact that
people were connecting on Twitter and
that we saw that post and cared about
her enough to respond that helps us
stand out and it's easier to win these
customers over for life and doesn't take
a lot of work and it's also fun to do so
those are some of the ways that we've
used it and hopefully through those
stories is something you can do for your
business as well if you guys liked the
video I love to hear comments if you
want to leave one under the video and
always love seeing those thumbs ups if
you can leave one under the video it
helps me know that you guys like these
and I'll keep making more for you
so thank you look forward to hearing
from you and we'll see you on the next
episode
you